turning water into wine
okay maybe like that's like his one of
his famous videos Jesus what Jesus did
right Jesus face
greatest hits
walk on water what does that do for the
the homeless
[Music]
did everybody hear about or see the new
Mr Beast video yeah what a piece of [__]
really
healed the blind that [__] what
happened absolutely give him the context
so Mr Beast made a video where he cured
a thousand people of blindness what a
piece of [__] [__] [__] I don't
like those videos though I wanted I want
them to give away like millions of
dollars he already
I wanted to like fill a whole house with
water and then and then swim through it
yeah dude I want to see him survive in
the Arctic for 24 hours is that why you
don't like this this video because I
thought it was really dull
yeah he needs to come out with some new
[__] like everybody eat a can of beans
and whoever farts the first has to suck
the other person's butt [__] yeah you
should have submitted that that's good
that's a good idea for a video yeah yes
up it he's upping it in the charitable
way why don't we just do that here he
needs to up it in the in the in the JK
party Ryan's like how can I give all my
money this idea
a 19 mil
so it really everybody was just no
everyone on Twitter that's what yeah
it's funny it started this like
negativity [__] storm out of nowhere and
people were like what so just for quick
context really cured people like
blindness and he's getting back a
thousand surgeries you can't make
anybody have paid for a thousand surges
for people that uh um basically it's not
like the blindness that like uh it's the
one where it's cataracts yeah it's
cataracts it's like that gray cloudy
film that's like in your eye that can be
removed and then you're given like a new
like [__] that's [__] dope yeah so
it's a 10 minute surgery that usually on
average is like 3 700 bucks for a
regular it's just priced out of a lot of
people's range yeah even though it's a
simple surgery so he [__] does this
for a thousand people basically pays for
a thousand people's surgery and then in
his videos literally people that are
just reacting to sight for like the
first time in a long time or or whatever
you know yeah but then the funny thing
is yeah Twitter for whatever reason
somehow manages to take the narrative or
the intention of it and then skew it
into some sort of like you're doing that
for clout yeah so there's a little bit
of this like but there's also a good
point in this which is like how [__]
up is it that in our world and in the
United States of America there are
people driving around who are trying to
drive around who can't drive around who
can't do normal things because of
blindness and our medical system being
as great as it is won't do [__] about it
right that and that's kind of an
interesting thing and all these
companies you know they all talk about
ad spends and all these big ad buys and
[__] you know making
gigantic floats for Macy's Thanksgiving
Day and like all that money could be
could be going towards something like
this and building good ways and you
can't even see them wait why you gotta
dunk on the [__] Macy's Parade I'm
not into phrase bro what you're telling
me you're on this [__] show that you
think companies spending money on floats
and parades is a waste of time he's got
to defend Pasadena dude dare you hey do
you go to the parades though [__] no
exactly you don't go to the Rose Parade
look outside my window and I watch it
from there with your non-blind eyes you
piece of [__] I I watch it from outside
the window you can see Colorado from
your yeah Prime real estate dude parades
are Antiquated gas leak wise parades are
Antiquated and I'm happy to talk about
it during a 20 minute off the Record
parades are lame as [__] though man you
guys suck just fast forward it so it
goes faster yes but what if you're live
but if you're live Joe's like oh [__] I
didn't even think about that yeah it is
a really I love that Narrative of like
it exposes so much of what doesn't get
done and it's like no my dad he wanted
to get uh but blood pressure medicine
through normal means in America I think
it came out to like 300 bucks a month
and in Chinese newspaper the back part
of the Chinese news paper is called like
loopholes
section if you go in the loophole
session the Chinese newspaper my dad
found this Canadian pharmacy and you
have to do it like a certain way but it
ended up being 16 a month plus blood
pressure medicine dude everything's
Dallas Buyers Club bro people go to
Mexico to get surgery people go to
Mexico to kick pick up prescription
drugs they go to Canada steroids but hey
our health care System
yeah there's there's also people
conspiring about the idea of the
biblical learning
because you know some people it's a
Biblical word oh the blind are being
cured yeah some some religious like
hardcores are like in the Bible it says
that you know because his name is the
Beast that in the end times someone will
appear and cure them and come dude Mr
Beast is the Antichrist yeah
Mr Beast is the Antichrist that is
probably the funniest thing I've ever
heard
the Antichrist is a YouTuber that's
tight that kind of like a million trees
which makes sense in our generation for
some weird that's what I'm saying it's
kind of perfect it's so fun honestly if
I was deep in the Bible like that I'd
probably believe it who in our time is
more Jesus like than Mr Beast that's
giving [__] away all the time right wow
Oprah no she's old maybe she used she
used to be kind of more she's not the
game dude yeah when she was giving away
Vans and stuff she was for sure
Antichrist yeah damn maybe Mr Beast I
think Mr Beast is probably the closest
thing he's not a Paul Walker maybe Joe
Malia he's the leading Jesus that
charitable he gives everything yeah but
you give the hookers what they need
that's true that's true you give the
most unexpected gifts yeah I did and he
hung Jesus did hang out with hookers and
accountants he did yeah I heard they
used to sit on his feet he dive more
into that yeah yeah he's out of the
Bible did you know that did you know
that Mr bees gives away so much [__]
that he has to [__] take debt on to
pay on for some stuff like but I have to
give collateral right to yeah I'm like
why didn't you just leave a little bit
of money left for you and your team but
he does he doesn't even care about money
he's even like money yeah he wants
growth he says he spends eight million
dollars on YouTube videos a month yeah
that's [__] crazy he's the man such a
great dude insane wow dude that's
literally the symptoms of the entirely
he is the Jesus of our time he is can we
read some tweets of people talking [__]
is it is there like a list of things
yeah there's ways to slow down this
video
I'm sorry what's the video about a few
speed bumps right
you know what I'm
known for a day and he'll know what he's
doing wrong I'm sorry sometimes I say it
and then I'm like and you can tell me to
go [__] myself he's like hey what hey
what's Mr B's ethnicity
here we go
what does he look like is he from
Central Florida or Northern Florida he's
from South Carolina is he a Sagittarius
no it's okay you don't have to I you
could tell me to [__] off I mean work
off what do you think about Mr Beast
versus Jesus just I'm just pitching
there turning water into wine
okay maybe like that's like his one of
his famous videos Jesus what Jesus did
right Jesus face
Jesus Greatest Hits billions Mr Beast
gets a [__] pizza guy to come to a
house he gives him the [__] house
yeah that's [__] cool Jesus could
only build tables and [__] Mr Beast is
building house
four bedroom to this pizza guy I'm
telling one of my favorite videos of Mr
Beast is he bought a car dealership and
then everyone every time someone comes
up he would be like all right how much
you want this car for they're like
um I think I'll pay like 3 000 Euros no
how about 1 000 and they're like wait
what no no okay okay I'll give you for
500 500 that's it final offer and
they're like 500 for this card they're
like oh God all right it's free just
take it
low balling them back yeah yeah it's
great dude meanwhile Jesus was like oh
come with me and [__]
and that's it Ah that's it that's all
you got dude Jesus water and Wine Walk
On Water what does that do for the the
homeless he's just showing up I saw a
lot of Chinese people doing teach the
technique yeah yeah only to David Blaine
do you think there were people in
Jesus's time well there were people
Jesus time huh that they're going to get
the rest of the people they're going why
are you turn all this water into wine
why don't you helping out like with
people with cataracts he did help that
one guy look at her ex you got it only
one guy and a guy turned water in the
wine everybody's like [__] yeah but do
you know the story of that tell us the
story that right Jesus at this party and
then they run out of wine right good
video they run out of wine and they have
all these [__] barrels right and then
Jesus just goes up to it and shakes a
stick and he's like yeah it's [__]
wide now right and then and then they
open it up and it's wine but like how do
we know it's just Jesus didn't just come
across the what the wedding the wedding
it's a plan I'm just pitching the
wedding they were ready for a lot of
people I assume and then they run out of
wine but then they have the amount of
wine for the amount of people I think
they just [__] misplaced the wine
Jesus knew about it and Jesus is just a
smart cat yeah he's just resourceful
he's good at finding things what if that
is his power he could just find wine
oh here are your eyeballs dude it's like
it's like Nikki I'm walking around my
place I'm like babe where's my [__]
glasses and she's like oh my God I have
to get up I'm gonna find him immediately
I'm like yeah I know babe I can't find
him anywhere she gets up and she finds
him immediately maybe Jesus is just that
way he just could find the thing that
you Jesus
but no I'm just saying I just don't know
what Jesus did that's good
you're kind of saying Jesus is overrated
a little bit a little bit yeah I think
he gets a lot of [__] shine a lot of
love we need a new Jesus it's like David
Copperfield versus
um Christmas yeah Chris Angel Is Not
freak he used his Royal name Mindfreak
can [__] fly yeah dude he like goes
through walls and [__] David Blaine's
like hey there's a Statue of Liberty and
now it's gone but like and Jesus Jesus
was never decked out in Affliction
that's true he didn't have any cool
change
so one of the Twitter people man I just
want to know dude I just feel like
that's such a good example of like you
just can't do anything good anymore like
the the cool thing is to just go against
it yeah everyone's just like when I was
reading I just want my comment scene so
I'm gonna say the opposite of what
everyone's saying yeah well there were
people that were just like mad about the
healthcare industry and there's people
that are mad at Mr Beast because it's
like you're doing it for attention and
then there's like so many different
conversations that were going on it
wasn't just like one group saying like
[__] you Mr Beast for being rich but I
feel like it's different for Mr Beast
because his whole Channel seems like
it's dedicated to give everybody at the
end of the day people still get
positively affected whether or not but
why are you monetizing bro it's like
it's like Ryan said though that is a
huge thing in like social media culture
nowadays where it's like people just
want to like have the hot take comment
that gets oh they love being the first
for that yeah you know what I mean it
doesn't matter if it's right or wrong
it's just like can I make the hot take
comment that gets the most interaction
yeah it's just like when when you said
the thing about the tourniquets and
suddenly everyone's a tourniquet expert
it's like people have never probably
administered it and for for real in
their life or just like well actually
like I just want to be the actually guy
so Bart's wrong if you did get shot 30
times 30 30 tourniquets is actually not
going to save you
well it's actually wrong if you get shot
you're supposed to [__] give head
first
and then a tourniquet
yeah it's like people just love being
that hote comment yeah just like Jesus
[Music]